it won't make them mad
the lord of juicers is back in the drama
spotlight for streaming our slash place
for those of you who don't know our
slash place is the home of a
collaborative artwork project taking
place on reddit it's a giant canvas
where any user can plop down a pixel
every 20 minutes and this year's event
got a boost in attendance after
streamers sent their communities to
participate you got xqc ms kip hassan a
bye destiny the entire event was an
absolute blessing for content the
biggest benefactor being the lord of
juicers himself xqc managing to break
his previous record of concurrent
viewers with 293
000 juicers and like a lot of anything
felix tries to participate in he got
into a bit of drama and like usual the
internet was cool about it but at the
end of the day pixels were placed and
tyler1 could not give a single i put
some pixels over over our pixels come
help us tyler i don't care bro